chi va piano va sano un proverbe italien
que l'on pourrait traduire en français
par qui va doucement va sûrement
expression qui colle parfaitement à la
stratégie de vaccination française
je ne confonds pas vitesse et
précipitation nous avons fait en france
un autre choix que je revendique qui est
de nous appuyer sur les médecins et
professionnels de santé de vacciner les
personnes âgées en ehpad et ne pas les
faire se déplacer
cela prend plus de temps au démarrage ce
délai jël assume
il est même revendiquer un démarrage
poussif assumée et revendiquée donc avec
à peine plus de 330 vaccination en
france depuis le début de la campagne
contre 2.7 millions aux etats-unis 1
million en israël 600 me le royaume uni
ou encore 130 mille chez nos voisins
allemands
la france loin derrière tous les autres
donc mais d'après le monsieur vaccin du
gouvernement tout s'explique
cette stratégie a une conséquence elle
force à aller plus lentement car il faut
savoir qu'il ya environ 14000 ehpad en
france et que le vaccin est difficile à
transporter difficile à conserver pour
certains toutefois ces questions de
logistique cash sans réalité tout autre
chose c'est une stratégie de lenteur
subi parce que nous ne sommes pas prêts
ça n'est pas une invention un tout petit
pas qu'on arrivera à convaincre les
français au contraire on va les
convaincre qu'en effet si on va si
lentement c'est qu'on n'est pas sûr de
soi et qu'il y à un danger pas sûr de
pas prêt depuis plusieurs jours les
critiques fusent et face à la polémique
sur la lenteur de la campagne de
vaccination le gouvernement a finalement
décidé de mettre un coup d'accélérateur
dans quelques semaines la vaccination a
été proposée à l'ensemble des personnes
âgées et nous serons au même niveau que
les pays qui ont procédé différemment
sans perte de chance au contraire nous
avons décidé en parallèle d'accélérer la
protection des publics prioritaires dès
lundi les soignants de 50 ans et plus
qui le souhaitent pourront se faire
vacciner dans les centres disposant déjà
de vaccins de plus avant le début
février deux premiers centres de
vaccination ouvriront en ville pour
commencer à vacciner les personnes âgées
de 75 ans et plus
puis les 65 ans et plus et c'est une
heure après ses tweets du ministre de la
santé
emmanuel macron à lui même lors de ses
voeux pour 2021 appelé chat mettre un
terme je cite à cette lenteur
injustifiée l'espoir est là dans ce
vaccin que le génie humain a fait
advenir en un an seulement
c'était impensable il ya encore quelques
mois je vous le dis avec beaucoup de
détermination ce soir je ne laisserai
personne jouer avec la sûreté et les
bonnes conditions encadrés par nos
scientifiques et nos médecins dans
lesquelles la vaccination doit se faire
et je ne le ferai pas davantage pour de
mauvaises raisons
une lenteur injustifiée s'installer
chaque français qui le souhaite doit
pouvoir se faire vacciner de manière
sûre et dans le bon ordre en commençant
par ceux qui présentent le plus de
risques
après une première livraison de 60 mille
doses de vaccin cinq cent mille doses
supplémentaires doivent arriver la
semaine prochaine et 500 mille autres
chaque semaine jusqu'à la fin du mois de
février
et elle vient peut être de là
l'accélération à présent revendiqué par
le gouvernement s'il ya en effet si peu
de vacciner en france c'est aussi parce
que le nombre de doses est aujourd'hui
limité ce choix de lenteur que disait
assumer le gouvernement serait en fait
un moyen de masquer une nouvelle car ans
après le scandale des masques et celui
des tests place un nouvelle polémique
cette fois sur les vaccins